can we actually take a tangent on the
tension on attention on the tangent how
old is the universe can you can you dig
in onto this number how do we know
currently with those I guess you said
five four or five uh significant uh
digits so we can come about it from two
different ways one uh basically they
rely on the most important number in
cosmology which is called the Hubble
constant the Hubble constant is this
weird number that has the following
units it has the units of kilometers per
second per megaparsec so it's a speed
per distance which means you multiply it
by distance and you get a speed and what
is the speed you're measuring well
you're measuring the speed of a distant
Galaxy at many mega parsecs away so a
Galaxy at one Mega particular this isn't
actually strictly true because of local
gravitational effects but if you go out
say one megaparse I would say that that
Galaxy's moving 72 kilometers per second
away from you and every Galaxy except
for the local very most local group
surrounding us maybe a half a dozen
galaxies out of 50 50 to sorry sorry out
of uh 500 billion galaxies to perhaps a
trillion galaxies so 12 out of that
number are moving towards us the rest
are moving away from us so that number
if you invert it if you say Well when
did those things last touch each other
all those galaxies now they're really
far apart we know how fast they're
moving away it's a very simple algebra
problem to solve when were they touching
that's where you get that number from so
there's the local 12 and then the rest
you know where the 12 yep and then
ignore the 12 and then look at the
others and yeah the then solve the
algebra problem
uh how does the and stuff in the
beginning the the mystery of that
beginning Epoch changed this calculation
of very little because actually we
understand
um how there's some other ingredients
that go into it namely how much dark
energy there is in the universe how much
dark matter there is in the universe how
much radiation light neutrinos Etc there
are and how much ordinary matter like
we're made up of neutrons protons
croutons okay so
what morons